vous êtes sûrement fasciné par les
romanciers les scénaristes de bd les
cinéastes
mais pour ces génies créatifs le
véritable talent ça consiste parfois a
imaginé un personnage et l'histoire qui
va avec
en s'inspirant du plus grand monstre de
créativité qu'ils soient la nature
c'est parti pour un petit top de
personnages de fiction qui sont inspirés
de maladie john ryan
on commence avec paint grimm savez la
chose dans les 4 fantastiques et bien
est ce que vous savez que les hommes de
pierre ça existe vraiment ils sont
atteints de phibro dysplasie aussi
fientes progressive qui est une maladie
qui a la particularité de transformer
les muscles en hausse la mutation
commence vers l'âge de 2 ans par la
nuque et les épaules puis elle évolue
par poussées vers le bas du corps
petit à petit tous les muscles
deviennent très dur la maladie de
l'homme de pierre comme on l'appelle est
extrêmement rare et elle touche une
personne sur deux millions elle est très
handicapant parce qu'elles touchent
aussi les tendons et fini par limiter
les mouvements et n'existe actuellement
aucun traitement pour la soigner
attention la fibre dysplasie aussi
fientes progressive ne donne pas
l'apparence extérieure de ben grimm
là ça ressemble plus à une maladie qui
couvre le corps de tumeurs bénignes la
neurofibromatose de type 1 ou maladie de
recklinghausen toujours dans l'univers
marvel
intéressons nous aux cas de croûtes et
non merci renaud groot c'est un
extraterrestre végétale à forme humaine
est bien notre brave gardien la galaxy
pourrait bien être atteint dépit des
remous dysplasie virus y forme qu'on
appelle aussi la maladie de l'homme
arbre c'est une maladie orpheline c'est
à dire qu'elle est très rare on en a
répertorié 200 cas dans le monde
mais ce dabul bandar et des décotes
varin ont été très médiatisées une
multitude de verrues se développe sur
les mains les pieds le visage le thorax
sans traitement et dans les cas extrêmes
les lésions peuvent proliférer envahir
léman jusqu'à leur donner un aspect des
corses
d'où le nom de la maladie qui se soigne
malheureusement très mal les traitements
permettent de ralentir l'évolution des
lésions ou de retirer le plus grosse
mais on ne sait pas stopper complètement
leur progression
a nantes les créatures de la pop culture
inspire des croyances d'haïti ou
d'afrique les zombies tels qu'on les
connaît dans les films c'est pauvre
bougre pourrait bien être atteint de
deux maladies bien distinctes le
syndrome de cotard et l'encéphalite
léthargie la première est une pathologie
psychiatrique aussi appelé walking
cordes syndrome le patient qu'on ait
atteint est persuadé d'être déjà mort et
immortel à la fois que six organes sont
en train de courir et qu'il est d'années
voire posséder la seconde maladie est
une infection virale du cerveau dont les
symptômes sont un état comateux avec
diminution des réactions aux
stimulations une faiblesse musculaire
avec tremblements et rigidité une
inversion du rythme jour nuit des
troubles du comportement mais aussi un
mutisme et une bonne pharyngite
avec tout ça on n'a pas un zombie
bascule un peu du côté de la mythologie
avec le loup garou sérieux mi homme mi
animal le loup garou peuple les romans
les comics des clips de michael jackson
les films et les forêts sombres les
experts bataille sur l'origine de la
légende méfier un médecin pouvait
examiner un loup garou sans danger
j'aurai un loup garou vegan par exemple
il lui diagnostiquent ray sans doute une
hypertrichose doublée d'une lycanthropie
clinique l'hyper tricot c'est un
développement excessif des poils plus ou
moins localiser ça peut ressembler à ça
mais ça peut aller un peu plus loin
voire beaucoup plus loin voilà ça
c'était pour le visuel pour le
comportement maintenant la lycanthropie
clinique c'est tout simplement une
maladie psychiatrique qui consiste à se
prendre pour un loup et donc à
reproduire les comportements de la bête
marcher à quatre pattes pousser des
hurlements et mordre et pour la pleine
lune ça c'est juste du folklore par
contre aller en termine en beauté avec
rien de moins qu'un homme le messieurs
dames le comte dracula en personne comme
tous les vampires en général ce brave
homme présente tous les signes de la
porphyrie et notamment d'une de ses
formes rares la porphyrie
érythropoïétine là bas
les porphyrie sont des maladies
génétiques du sang causé par un déficit
dans steam est caractérisée par
l'accumulation dans l'organisme de
substances appelées porphyrines ce qui
donne une liste de symptômes assez
troublante
écoutez plutôt une eric redon si les
dents tout ça normalement se déforme
prennent une coloration rougeâtre
avec en plus les gencives qui se
rétractent qui renforce l'impression que
les dents sont très longues
une photo dermatoses au contact du
soleil la peau se couvre de cloques avec
des sensations de brûlure qui pousse les
patients à vivre dans la pénombre une
anémie c'est à dire un manque
d'hémoglobine qui donne aux malades un
teint très pâle et dont on raconte
qu'elle était traité à l'époque en leur
faisant boire du sang de transfusion old
school qui marche pas très bien là pour
fear et entraîne aussi une croissance
anormale des poils des cheveux et des
ongles ce qui correspond en tout point à
la description de dracula dans le roman
original de bram stocker pour finir
sachez qu'il est contre indiquée aux
patients atteints de porphyrie de manger
de l'ail parce que ça aggrave les
symptômes et que la maladie peut donner
des troubles neuropsychiatriques comme
des accès de violence
or avec la porphyrie dracula voilà ce
top est terminée posez moi toutes les
questions vous voulez sur la santé dans
les commentaires j'y répondrai en vidéo
et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à
détester